Hey Al's gotten best my name is Peter
power and welcome back to Conker's Bad
Fur Day what the [ __ ] is he doing
it's chocolate milk my favorite all
right conquer we should go either left
or right - naughty or nice
I which one bread what okay I can't hear
you what a not day it doesn't even say
naughty
silly silly bruh is not an ayah nasty
nasty love the texture here on the
ground by the way speaking of textures I
know some of you suggested you can play
this on the Xbox like a we need to it
like a remake with better graphics but I
don't know I liked a Nintendo 64
graphics they're so colorful and awesome
and I got this what that voice acting
really good no it's not me I swear to
god it's summing up the [ __ ] no it's
mine [ __ ] alright it looks like I can't
steal it
let's get the chocolate maybe let's do
it give it another go sign out of it
Josh
not what okay okay well we can come to
bed I [ __ ] love the accent all right
Jason well that plan kind of failed Oh
chocolate meat chocolate hello the
health bar is chocolate [ __ ] love
chocolates right conquers all right when
did the hive go I guess I need a better
plan let's go on this thing oh hello
that kinda scarecrow I miss you
right what seemed to be a problem oh
yeah you'll need manual oh really - yeah
there's a work watching posture okay how
much how much ah
got any MEPs a box what kind of
shoreland this same drug well $10 okay
long time what you got mind you I see a
prostitute put the [ __ ] your [ __ ]
slack $10 love man you a long time god
damn it
that [ __ ] slide well it doesn't look
like we can do much progress over there
either breast what about here yeah I
know right I was trying to help you
what did conquer say hey keep crying
like a [ __ ] I really know where it is
bow [ __ ] ho Jesus how the music
changes right away also very very
nostalgic feeling of this game I know
did you bros have a Nintendo 64 I think
my favorite game on a Nintendo 64 was
starfox starfox 1664 I played that game
so friggin much alright how do we steal
this back I'm just gonna [ __ ] work
take it and go in here
whoa I did not work at all shits in ten
oh I shouldn't run into grass I'm so
stupid oh [ __ ] we died
Oh No conquer what will happen what well
this is creepy
where the [ __ ] are we yes Jesus is that
you yes is that you Satan Oh what the
[ __ ]
I don't know huh
my name's Greg sup Greg I mean maybe
don't laugh [ __ ] you little man
well how many people have you met
that'll make what what am I supposed to
look like yeah that's a good point
goodbye gaga
uh-huh fair name the squirrel conquer
this ground nicer name yeah you would
have to be a [ __ ] squirrel wouldn't
you why why is there a problem with that
well your fate
actually my fate bloody cats such a pain
in half you're one of these special
cases oh really
Oh God hey according to the powers that
be understand my god
oh [ __ ] okay ready laughs I think faking
I'm not that not crack okay well I'll be
off then just you wait
smartass don't get out of it that easily
the thing is you may not begin
that doesn't mean your time guy you just
have a few more shall we say thankful
mmm alright my cat I got it here and a
little well love these tail things
squirrels town yeah you can get them
I'll give you an extra chance understand
um
well sounds a bit strange but okay James
that's bloody dare y'all day to get you
little prick right nice shoes by the way
I [ __ ] love them right
Wow babies everywhere [ __ ] some over my
fantage a yeah
alright luckily we have one of those
tails so we can just go back in the game
all right cool what all right it's
returning me to the dark side I'm not
sure which side is a good side honestly
that's [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] cats man
I don't know squirrels have that power
did you know that all right we're back
in the game
without your tail what a weird life
honestly we can grab the chocolates well
I know how to get the Beehive now anyway
so let's let's do that right away
shall we browse it's just like one of
those back in the day when I fly on my
skate and then I go okay don't run
through here because it makes me slow I
should have noticed that and they fly so
they're not slowed by it it still
appears doesn't even realize all right
let's give that [ __ ] her hive yeah
Hey all right we can skip these kill yay
I'm not a shouting go go go go go go go
I can do it I can do it Russ
I can do it it's [ __ ] Bing
I never made it this far before holy
[ __ ] I don't even see what I'm going I
know nobody's no one does
das Jeffrey mm suck on that [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
what are those boobs that's right whoa
whoa mother buzzer oh [ __ ]
they actually kill them
that's intense man there we go
they all died they're all brutally
murdered Thank You mr. screw
yeah well none of this would have
happened if it were that no-good husband
of mine it's gone off you know I wonder
why not cousin surprise ha ha ha I love
I conquer and I always responded the
same way
well good service to the BU community ha
ha so cute with this what is it what the
[ __ ] is that money yay ha ha ha
conquer your silly man this game is so
[ __ ] weird ok cool we got our cash we
can now go over to the prostitute or
whatever the [ __ ] he is honestly jeez I
don't even want to know let's get this
chocolate first oh wait I don't even eat
it what the [ __ ] do i oh it's a
slingshot cool I'll just shoot these
[ __ ] what's up
hopefully it's not a giant cake who
plays with the inverted control
seriously
I just offended like 300 people who
actually use emergent controls seriously
though why I don't get it oh [ __ ] it's
coming closer vibe nail that [ __ ] yo
you like me
all right so now we can go past whatever
the [ __ ] those were beetles I don't get
it dad do that dinner today
hey what's going on concrete wait oh
that way mm-hmm that way smells a bit
hmm
go over the poo way I press what do you
think way all the way man poor way all
the may assets and oh he has a gas mask
how convenient
close back at 10:00 [ __ ] hmm 10 o'clock
time is in caca no well let's love out
come back later then
ah I don't know if I want to come back
later conquer well as would same we
would have to go back into the non poof
smelly place which makes me a little sad
I wanted to go into the post smelly
place let's go here then oh wait okay
we're at the castle yes the doctor is
key elements in experimentation we have
uh-huh okay Oh what is the problem
hmm seems to be a mi plus milk shadow
some experiments yeah yeah as Leila
thought I saw that very well see that I
[ __ ] love the doctor it's like the
best villain ever I don't even know if
it's a villain yet honestly alright
let's check beside a lot of stuff going
on here
I guess the teddies are like our enemies
are within the [ __ ] god damn tip alright
this is easy
naylet oh oh oh [ __ ] that was close
what's going on here friends die die
you're gonna [ __ ] die all of you oh
that's right I killed Rubert I can't
Sarah stop sad I get the back here stop
running you will only make it harder for
yourself come here Sarah
I love conquer space
come here honey carry that come on man
what's going on here I'll attack this
first picture for my I can relate that's
good for me then yeah show you what I'm
gonna do I say I tell you what I'm gonna
do you get me a freakin Mouse I was
actually just doing man
just maybe that's me man just one more
thing to say just one more thing you
know I can say my friend Bert just
mention my name Jack and everything'll
be just dandy
Bert Jack got it die die hey what's up
all right you look deeper
Oh Bert Albert wicka wicka shoot a good
nipple
what is everybody trying to do well but
aren't you a [ __ ] bro oh I get it I
get it pits get it do you get it
do you get it have you gotten to that I
can see you being all confused it's
really kid kids have this no problemas
as one would say um I think at least I
don't know have you got him yet you got
it before me hey don't try to be smart
afterwards not cool
I bet like both Spicoli watches are its
you don't have to be smart to figure out
a [ __ ] Mouse with me cheese okay how
about that let's just let's just leave
it on that what's up [ __ ] looks like I
say let's even have a mouse I'm out
shut up oh no oh no all right it looks
like I will have to do that again
I love the [ __ ] music come here
little [ __ ]
that's right it's Taylor time just don't
squeeze me please I'm very gentle I can
just [ __ ] walk here I'm so stupid no
I can't [ __ ] he escaped that little
[ __ ]
mmm
Adam Adam oh I got you Adam don't try to
run now it's too late it's too late to
run well it's your lucky today Adam
let's let's get
Christina Hager sorry you could run from
me huh
ain't nobody running from turds except
ruber tanana but they were lucky
don't kill me please don't kill me
please turds Australia Chris is very
flat fragile there we go there we go
quite splendid quite splendid ha ha ha
ha ha all right where is that [ __ ]
rat
well there's someone up there let's see
it wait now [ __ ] shut up cheese good
there we go take em no that's okay it's
not [ __ ] okay hey you are thank you
up eh
Hey oh no oh that one alright let's see
if we can do it come on come on clap for
me brush tap thank you
shut that was close good thing you were
clapping you aren't clapping well [ __ ]
em [ __ ] Oh
how do ya laughs okay we're good we're
good thank you thank you can stop it
stop clapping just cry all right what do
we got
yeah
ha ah for [ __ ] sake smells like aa
gift bag
do it now little bit a fun job Lafitte
there we go thank you can run couldn't
you all right I need you brother
clapping this time again I said clapping
not fapping Jesus sometimes I wonder
about your breasts okay
last last one take this sacrificial
cheese al always says one more should do
it should do what oh whoa that should do
it
oh the [ __ ] Oh
oh well that gets majesty
it looks like a watermelon I did that oh
that's nice
it's still alive - that's that's really
nice it's still farting it's sickly
[ __ ] [ __ ] well what are we doing
now mad [ __ ] now farts good national
moment longer there thank you very much
mr. screw any time man there's something
real neat inside that farm
you gotta get in there Sonny Sonny sue
we'll go there for you I still don't
understand why she jumped down because
the rat died I really don't get it but
hey I'm not the developer don't get
don't really not gonna get too much into
it
all right no I can go right Oh money
give me that be actually here
yes give me that cash get that dollar I
think arounds on me I'm gonna get pink
tonight yeah yeah they're not quite sure
well after all
quite quite nice quite splendid it's
gonna are they open now it's a ten ten
o'clock all right cool now we can go
into the yeah that that one thing where
you got that thing but I think I
recorded up virgin Abra's I hope you
enjoyed I [ __ ] love this game it was
a bit hard to get into there for a while
there it's cool it's called how people
are enjoying it I'm enjoying it you're
enjoying it okay I'm joking a little bit
too much I'm just kidding I'm doing too
much to wave but you love Dora Explorer
app you love it
say you love what's wrong with me today
thousand bridge
I don't know what's gonna happen me but
that's the door behind me